good evening and welcome today the
European premiere of Luc Besson's
valerian city over thousand fighters
[Applause]
the most fun I've ever had me with
though you go to work you put on the
superhero speak and you play pretend the
best part is being Jane becomes Alerian
obsessed loli would surely like the
costume and just be so sure and seeing
him with Kara I've seen many of the
actors and actresses and I know valerian
and Laura lein for many years and I just
know it's them there's only so much that
I can describe with words it's really a
visually thrilling film and I can't with
you guys yeah I mean I don't know what
made me cry and drop my Georgia to film
or watching this live you're being asked
to be in the film by liberal
neighbors next thing that I will work
harder than anyone and I would be too I
can be on Ordnung I'm a big blue press
on banner he's a great guy and this is a
passion project for him so I really
wanted to go both when Luke but
SoundCloud you just you just don't even
have to show up my mind is blown you
know any kind of technology catch up
with Lucas on graduation if it's mine
well thank you everyone for coming out
you are so amazing thank you guys it
means so much
[Applause]
you
you